el de leslie rocha es el segundo
asesinato violento contra una mujer
transgénero en méxico en menos de una
semana su cuerpo fue encontrado el
sábado en la mañana en medio de una
dantesca escena en una vivienda en
ciudad juárez en el estado de chihuahua
donde se había llevado a cabo una
protesta anteriormente por el aumento de
los crímenes de odio contra esta
comunidad entonces tan matizando los
marcos muy feo para que se haga justicia
porque ellos merecen respeto porque
hacen eso porque quiero justicia para mi
sobrina tres días antes fue hallada
muerta también en deplorables
circunstancias la activista transgénero
mireya rodríguez lemus sobre el caso de
mireia la fiscalidad chihuahua aseguró
que no quedaría impune pero la realidad
es otra según el más reciente informe
del observatorio nacional de crímenes de
odio contra personas el gti se calcula
que en méxico por cada caso visible al
tres invisibles a finales de agosto ye
nine huerta otra activista trans fue
encontrada muerta dentro de su casa en
tijuana con diversas heridas y golpes
estos asesinatos amplificaron el temor
de la comunidad transgénero local
ya estamos un poco asustada atemorizadas
temor a salir a la calle
ya no sabemos qué hacer porque ya son
muchos crímenes de odio contra la
población trans muchos se preguntan qué
está haciendo realmente la policía para
detener estos asesinatos en el país sólo
el año pasado 117 personas de la
comunidad lgbti fueron asesinadas en
méxico casi un 30% más que en 2018 esta
es la cifra más alta desde el 2015 según
el grupo local de defensa letra s